before to start Four Words about
me my past is a Colorful Experience but
the Constant is I work with data and
code S my psd and Now I'm a data and
Automation Specialist for ingestion and
analysis
and
prediction
visualization for monitoring or for the
business  What will I tell you
today show
you our goal and a possible
Solution
[Music]
After short introduction of the tools
that see in Action in the demo I hope We
also
have Time For best
practice
noteb in our
laptop
codeit the we are
using learn dataset  so few Records but
we want to
optimize
our parameters Rom
Search
We
obs that we have to use
more
iterations So we
Try with More
and Why Does the Process no longer
end
[Music]
Less Time And We need to use more
resources but not in our
laptop we can
use library
or libraries
that They are useful to to
manage resources in the cloud
and What
[Music]
features These libraries
have
Ok so I'm a
student and
if I have a wonderful laptop
I
would
even need the
Cloud So we want  to
start We Open Source libraries ok
and I
have I
have
chosen
chosen to Present Dusk Cloud provider
library to you because
Well we can
use that library with desk
library
and for every Fing We will use
ok
dkk [
Music]
ISP
par for
Cus
and use  One
Dusk is our layer to manage
multiple processes in Parallel in our
laptop it
MIM data frame like pandas
anday
like
Operations
like Is The
collection as to
par statements in our code
That
ISS ext concurrent features
interface and Yes
distributed is the Collection that we
see
today  but Dusk is a big library
[Musica]
and it has many
integration
with other libraries and today We will
see the
one with learn and J
Well We use
the distribut
collections to create a dataset
cluster
Dask
Cluster
[Musica]
are of Cluster the
client Ok  the client is our notebook or
our
code the Python instance
inv the Creation
Cluster and the mapper is the
orchestrator of the workers and the
workers are computes the tasks our
statements that we want to
parallelize
so
with You
can scale the Python to you
love ok but  we have a
problem the time of Our
processes in our laptop is very Long So
we also want to
use the
Cloud
today
the Top 10 of the Cloud
provider is this and the Das Cloud
[Music]
provider
support Four of them I don't
know  last One
is
Will use aws Cloud provider Because I
know
it
so it is not important Which Cloud
provider you use
or our goal is to improve the timing of
Our
processes we
are with the the
code What I'll show you
now
we see the code
[Music]
and Will configure aws account create
our
Ass
and
we
will see the code modified to use the
Cloud resources so let's go to the
code
Ok This is the
[Music]
Alessandra S could Please Little
screen Yes are the
Brows in  Little B we can the speaker
perf Thank you
OK OK
perf in the first Block We have
the packages that we want
use job to par
our
Lear
Colle that
We will use to create
the the Cluster and
some System libraries
and Well in this case It's only  a plus
but the data frame
ofk That is the of pandas
and the
libraries
About To Import the
dataset
the randomized Search CV
and the
algor
and
Block
Ok so We
use five
iterations
and
the the workers are to like the CPU
that have Has
the the environment  that
We
use and Well we can explore the data the
data is
the digits so Images Collection
and we will use
the Array version
in this case the
numbers
TG and Yes the
is Zer
number and also in the
Array so the Method methods are two One
To  load
the the
data data
[Music]
isay that
Array and the target target is an Array
with
Which Number Is in the in the
and the methods
[Music]
ofk Cluster is this
and
[Music]
Ok the statement principal statement is
this with this statement  We create a
local
Cluster
with workers because
workers
is CP
[Musica]
cpus and Yes important to define a Limit
of Memory That the
Cluster can use and Yes we can define
other other
parameters not
important
so i
define take the time before
the principal statement
to
compare the local Cluster
and the Cluster in in the
Cloud in in this
case The
Cluster
takes
minutes Sorry Five
Seconds to to be
available
[Music]
and we have the details of the clients
and the Cluster So we have one scheduler
and in this case two
workers
Ok Well in in this Block
We
basically We Get
the the data
and in this Block We
initialize the Model and The Random
Search
C
the principal Block
is
in this
line may you
[Music]
know the T job
that it
[Music]
starts
One  at a
time
and if We use the
Job the Method
parall
[Music]
back
parameter
use the T
Cler with
jobb and when we execute the Search Fit
Method
we don't create One training
job
job training job in in
Parallel but in this
case we
have only two workers
So we
can we have only
two training Jobs at a
time and
parameters I
configure for
Random CV we
have
iterations and
the the time
of
Process
[Music]
minute The
Last Point is important because we
close the Cluster
so
[  Music]
in
Ok
Time
need configuration ews to create an
account and then to create the
credential that we can use in our
notebook and in our
laptop
aws Ok the program
to to use the api of
aws Cloud provider
And We need to configure the
credentials
that  We Just
created
and
After We
will see the the code
modified Ok
so
Now Don't
create a New an account
but [
Musica]
SL all
link
links create the account
and all steps [
Musica]
That
[Musica]
how to create the credentials Because
yes It's important
and Yes in in this
[Music]
case use the
aws My aws
account to
see
steps
and
Yes so to
[Music]
create the credentials We need
to log in in our WS account
and go on Security
credentials and we can see
S
with We
need
Active And So we can
create
this Well for
All our actions so it's
ok and then we can define
something
like
ours we can use more If
You If you
[Music]
want
more It's important to define A
description and then we can
create  the ssk the ssk is like a
username and the password so
secr and
this Pay is important to use
in in our
laptop
so we
can log in the code Space I
use
this like my
laptop and now
eh
We can see How to install aws
config
created  Install
AW P
[Music]
ok We
need libraries ok and
aws Comm
line so
We
use R that
we
I don't remember
is After or not now I
can
Ok
So we can
use only to
install all packages Python packages in
our environment in this  case I
have
And after create
account
create the
credentials we can
configure the
WS
program and
it
[Music]
Ask Ask
the
ok and we can cofe
this
and
it also asks the
secret in this we
can
create
Copy
[Music]
par Reg
name Ok
all
When
you don't
use
[Music]
Yes the
ass we can
deactivate this Ok or
Delete
Ok It's
important Ok
so
aws Cloud provider but
also Aure and
Google
platform the
same are
many a lot of Region Where
you can
work
We Today  We work on
Frankfurt so the Reg name is Eu Central
One
in this
case
Ok Enter
[Music]
and output form is the default and we
can
see
[Music]
file
modified is
this and the Format the full Format is
this When We use
default the  our
code Us
directly
with
also with All our our
code Ok in this
case We need to use Another
account not
Mine
Another and
ok
So
we installed
awhp
and all Python packages
We configured the
credentials and Yes Now we can see the
[Music]
ehm del  notebook
modified can try to use
the
so the
title different but in the Block of
configuration we
have two New
libraries the
Bot is the SDK of
aws Cloud
provider
is
the layer for api of
aws
andk
Cloud provider
is our layer
to from Dusk Cluster to
aws  and I
have I
Used this parameter to define If we
[Music]
Oh
only minutes ok Ah
ok
so
in
in on the Cloud We will
use
more
workers
and the only
modification important modification is
this When are in local We use the same
statement local Cluster
with some
workers
and
[Musica]
Cloud on the Cloud in this case
is the
clusters named forate and Where We need
[Musica]
to learn and then we It's important to
define CPU and memory of the
worker here there are Only
[Musica]
the new
parameters and Division of the Cluster
is the same
but Yes we have More
workers and Yeah
I run this
notebook with two workers
and
Yes
Take
LS
local
and
Yes with more
workers the Process
takes few
Seconds
and the last Point is Yes We need to
Delete the  Cluster on
aws so
SD
WS Ok
so the results is
this
We
basically the
processes Finish time in the because we
have More workers and
I
think we
have minutes
for
not So we are like 10 minutes
After but Maybe we can Yes Maybe we can
wrap up  in this moment and if you have
any questions You can use the q&a and
also know if you want
to some Contact to you
email know
account any more questions can Contact
you
yes by github and Yes by email It's not
problem
My
Oh
Only
You Let meare  for every Ok thank
you
Yeah I don't have any Time
[Music]
so Well
I P the slides in in the kab repository
that I posted in
the in the chat
and